because sometimes it's freaking hard
like when it's you you feel you know
you're you every day and it's hard to
notice
changes when you're standing in the
middle of it you know you're in the
forest but then when you get those
breakthroughs where you all of a sudden
are like oh that's so nice wow i get it
so i a theme that that that comes up
again and again that i'm really curious
about is this theme of loss
and
i'm curious where
that pain comes from you said you did
therapy so i'm curious if like your
therapist has kind of
dug into that and tried to figure out
kind of what it is about loss that's
scary is it a is it an anxious
attachment wound was there like
inconsistent uh you know parenting along
the way because you know i i have that
where i was have you heard about um
attachment styles
yes
so i mean i was totally anxious
attachment where i was afraid of being
abandoned and it really was rooted in
the fact that
it wasn't my parents were wonderful
they're still married but my mom stayed
home with me and my dad would go to work
and i barely saw him i don't think i saw
him like at all during the week and i
just see him on the weekend so what a
kid learns is that i don't know when
dad's coming back i have no rationing
skills to go dad's at work i just know
that he's kind of there and not there
and so inconsistent
appearance of parents is what can cause
that abandonment wound and so that was
like one part i mean trust me there was
mom part two the process this past year
but that was the dad part so i'm
wondering if there's an abandonment
wound somehow or or what could have what
drives this this fear of of loss
yeah definitely um i am the exact same
way like i feel like i saw and like
heard so much of myself and like
everything you just said just um yeah
the dynamic my family dynamic i also
grew up in like a very strict italian
household so it was like you know dad is
very like there's like not a lot of
emotional um like outpouring there dad
worked a lot mom worked a lot um so yeah
there was a lot of that there's a lot of
inconsistency i mean i grew up in a very
lovely loving household my parents are
still together thankfully so you know
but and then also throughout the like
along the way just in school growing up
in different relationships that i
developed whether it was in friendships
or
in my adult life like romantic
relationships there's a lot of like
similar patterns that were being
repeated of just like something changing
somebody meaning
and um even to this day like it's very
hard for me to open up to people
romantically or in friendship just
because i you know i just have this fear
of them just like
leaving you know um especially in my job
and what i do now is very hard to be
trusting of people because i've seen it
so many times you know just like being
used by people or just
people just completely switching it's a
it's a very fleeting you know like
friendships are very fleeting in this
business especially and it's very hard
to weed out you know the the real ones
versus you know the not real ones so i
feel like it's just been kind of a
pattern in my life before and after my
career of just like it's like
abandonment thing i do i do have that it
was hard for me to admit too because
it's like it sounds so childish like oh
you didn't abandon me but it's so true
and like our inner child i'm a lot older
than you so i have that and i just said
it and i'm almost 40 i'm 39 so
i know i think it's i mean like they say
that's one of the first things you learn
in therapy if you do go to therapy is
like your inner child still lives oh
yeah
it sounded like such a weird like campy
strange thing to do to like talk to it
and like you know nurture it but
i found myself being so emotional doing
that like i've had sessions where like
i've talked to myself as a kid and i
didn't know why i would get so emotional
about it but you realize like how much
there is that innocent kid in there that
just wants to be loved and nurtured and
is so scared you know
oh you're a cancer i so i took a couple
levels of astrology so something in me
said i need to look up your chart to see
what is in there and
a lot of things make sense but first off
you're a cancer which is all about the
family it's all it's the mother it's the
mother sign
and so and you're a ton of pisces which
is i get it because my mercury is in
pisces which is the way my brain thinks
and so your mercury's there your
ascendant's there your venus and mars
are there and which is all super airy
and flowy and like dreamy like i bet you
could sit there and just like
days off for a while
right and just think of amazing stories
but that makes sense that you
like feel that for your inner child
because like the nature of you is so
motherly so what i mean i've done the
same thing like i remember last year
when i was getting
more connected to my inner child i would
literally hug myself i'd literally like
go like this
and i'd hug myself and i would cry and
i'm like wow and so my inner child went
from this like seeing it for the first
seeing her for the first time like in a
concrete dome like tucked away no words
no nothing to like all of a sudden she
was kind of down at the bottom of the of
the tower and she was like at the
doorway and she was like you know
standing up and she was kind of short
and she didn't still say anything and
then all of a sudden she came out and
now she like walks with me and is like
bubbly chatty and she always tells me
i'm like what should i be working on
she's like just play play
um but i'm wondering what that
dialogue's been like with your inner
child and if it's changed
um i was like super not in touch with it
like for a long long time again like i
just kind of got through things by like
suppressing and suppressing and just
being like oh that's not attached to
this or that's fine like you know i just
kind of always like pushed it down so i
feel like there was no dialogue at all
like i just like pushed her down
completely
um and
yeah it was just never something that
like i just always thought you know like
you grow up and life changes and that's
it and you don't realize how much
you are affected by things when you're
younger and how much that innocence is
still in you like ultimately yeah we're
grown up and we have you know new views
and you know new experiences but
ultimately like all we are is just like
children and innocent people just that
want to be loved and want companionship
and want to be understood and um so i
think that dialogue has changed
completely with not only the way i speak
to my inner child per se but just the
way i speak to myself now um yes you
know it's the same thing i mean it's
essentially the same thing 100 yeah just
a part of you it's just that innocent
part of you that's just trying to
navigate life that you know just trying
to understand and i think for me weirdly
like i i got a dog in the pandemic as a
lot of us did i you know got a covet
puppy and it wasn't like it kind of
clicked for me when i would like
look at her even now i look at her and
i'm like look at this like little being
this poor little thing just like relies
on me for
you know like for simple things like
food water love like to be nurtured like
if i neglected this little dog like she
would not survive in the world like she
relies on me so heavily and i just
thought like i would mom
yeah yeah you know i would i would like
never do
anything to harm this little being but
then i was looking at how i treat myself
and i'm like some days like i don't eat
because i'd be so depressed like i'd be
too depressed to eat i wouldn't feed
myself i wouldn't sleep
i wouldn't like i'd talk to myself
horribly i would do everything that i
would never do to this little being that
i love so much and i'm like how do i do
it to myself then like why do i deserve
the things that
like someone else would never deserve
you know and that's when it really
clicked i'm like why am i not treating
myself with the same care with the same
level of love and patience and care and
honestly that's when it clicked like i
have to start treating myself as if i
were treating like my dog or like a baby
you know or like someone that i love
um because we always tend to get the
brunt of our
our own judgment you know and oftentimes
the way that we speak to ourselves is
never how we would speak to to someone
we love you know so that's honestly when
it clicked is when i was started caring
for someone
else you know for this little
thing this little tiny
bundle of love you know